hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 12 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there's so much happening tarp it
was the big character there's a bunch of
zoom stuff that I have to talk about a
bunch of new 52 comics that I have to
explain so here we go
there's also a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway that starts now all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
any comment will do you don't have to
say you're entering the giveaway so here
we go tarp it this is really his episode
but it subtly turned into a Joe West
episode there are really so many big WTF
so I'm gonna go ahead and do a top 10
I'll explain everything as we go along
so number 10 meet tarpit he's a
character from the comics brought in by
geoff johns and he even tried to join
the Suicide Squad during blackest night
so they changed a few things about his
origin story from the comics he was kind
of a dirtbag but his ability was astral
projection he was able to animate
inanimate objects with his spirit it got
stuck in a vat of tar on the TV show
they just used the traditional route of
using the particle accelerator explosion
but it works the same way and by the end
of the episode he actually looks like
traditional comic book tarpit with one
of my favorite bait related lines from
the episode number 9 WTF wall-e versus
his family while he's kind of keeping
them at arm's length he keeps talking
about how he is obsessed with speed with
racing iris is trying to help him
because she sees an opportunity to work
on a case so she uses one of his races
she is trying to help Wally but she's
also trying to get a good story out of
it too the reason she's really pissed at
Joe like on the other side of this is
because he's acting more like Wally's
friend Joe is just happy that Wally
wants to be in their lives it really
takes the accident to crystallize their
relationship but that's just gonna
continue to develop Wally getting closer
with Iris and Joe in the next couple of
episodes number 8 WTF Harrison wells
makes a Speed Force battery to siphon
Barry's power here's where things get
really exciting so if you didn't read
the new 52 run Harrison wells is doing a
lot of things like Darwin Elias he's a
scientist that Barry starts working with
he tries to develop all these awesome
new things to help humanity just like
Harrison wells did on earth - he's kind
of like the inventor like he invented
the metahuman watch but his relations
turns kind of sour he winds up creating
a giant speed force battery to harness
the Flash's power and use it as a clean
source of energy but he's really shady
about it so that's basically what
Harrison wells did in this episode he
used the Flash's power in a real a shady
way obviously it's part of the zoom plot
so it's a little bit different but it
seems like earth to Harrison wells
has a lot of that Darwin Elias character
in him now obviously they're not doing
an exact storyline from the comics don't
think of it that way
just think of the TV show is borrowing
character traits number 7 WTF Barry
versus tar pit round 1 with the help of
Cisco's metahuman tinder where can I
sign up for that that would be awesome
maybe we can find golden gliders profile
you can kind of see where they're going
they use their genius level Cisco
nitrous bomb and 4th grade science to
defeat tar pit number 6 WTF Barry works
with Harrison wells
Wow you know the last Harrison wells he
was kind of like a dad to me even though
he was a psychopath I love the way that
one he's able to speed read the hell out
of that book and two he just casually
references Harrison wells the EU bard
dawn Harrison wells like it's no big
deal
really this is all to create tension
with earth - Harrison wells who's trying
to keep team flash at arm's length so he
doesn't get attached because he's trying
to save his daughter and he has to
essentially neutralize the flash for
zoom even though he gets there
eventually I was actually really
surprised that they had to reveal this
quickly
number five WTF Barry's feeling sick
feeling slow Caitlin says he's 2% slower
to be precise and as they talk as Barry
talks about his fears of not being able
to save everyone
Harrison wells you see the camera just
slowly zoom in on him is he's like BAM
finally I did it I'm the one that did it
Joe's on a tear in this episode knocks
him the F out but you have to remember
this is after what happened to Iris so
number four WTF iris takes glass to the
shoulder it looked like it was really
close to her heart but in the scene at
the hospital Joe's like it only got your
shoulder so she's fine not nearly as bad
as what happened to felicity on arrow
but a very similar device in injury
crystallizing relationships in the group
but it but it X's like this catalyst for
wal idea closer to his family
Joe dad's the eff up tells why look I'm
not mad at you but this is what families
do we worry about each other we think of
each other first before we think of
ourselves let's see if I can use a few
here shifting into reverse number 3 WTF
wally races it almost gets taken out by
tarp it
pretty good special effects but this is
where we're getting into comic book
tarpit territory he has his first
encounter with the flash which is
actually a big deal because he's
obsessed with speed it was an interview
with the actor people asked him what do
you think that Wally thinks of the flash
and he's like he probably thinks the
flash is really badass I don't think Joe
or iris is going to tell Wally that
Barry is the flash anytime soon but that
is gonna be a thing while he's
developing a relationship with the flash
and then with Barry's separately from
that loves the flash thinks he's totally
badass not so hot on Barry because Barry
represents the life that he could have
had the stuff that he missed with Joe
and iris number two WTF Harrison wells
gives zoom Barry Speed Force and like a
true addict his hand shakes as he
injects himself it courses all through
his veins
did it not just look like a drug addict
getting a fix like he slowly calms down
a little bit but he's like it's not
enough I gotta have more got to have
more why does he need more and why does
he look like an addict who it all ties
in with my number one WTF Wally West
explains to Iris why he races he is
trying to get this feeling back that he
used to have the last time that he was
really really happy and safe now what
does that sound like does that not sound
exactly like Daniel West in the new 52
for those that haven't read the comic
this is a big new 52 explainer it's all
about the reverse-flash of the new 52
which is why after this episode I'm
reordering my list of people that I
think zoom is Wally just shot straight
to the top because it sounds like zoom
might be an earth 2 version of Wally
West with a Daniel West arc from the
comics if you never read the new 52 a
lot of people really didn't like it
because it rewrote continuity in this
really big way
there was no Daniel West before the new
52 iris West family is like this really
awful broken family it's very very
different from the classic comics but
essentially Daniel West is irises little
brother he grows up as this maladjusted
teen he tries to run away from home
his father's abusive but he remembers
this time when he was I think eight or
nine years old he tries to get back
there after he
it's a new an accident that gives in the
speedforce but unlike Barry who's had
this really positive life and becomes
the flash turns into a hero Daniel has
had a very hard life been to prison been
in all kinds of terrible situations and
it just completely messed up in the head
then he gets into an accident with the
Speed Force but the way he uses the
Speed Force is very different from the
flash when Daniel West is the flash he
finds that he has the ability to reverse
time in the more Speed Force that he
absorbs the further back in time he can
travel but on the flip side of that
Barry also moves time forward with the
Speed Force remember new 52 very very
different explanation for how the Speed
Force works than the classic comics so
Daniel West goes around trying to kill
other speedsters absorb their Speed
Force so he becomes more powerful and
can go back in time 20 was a child
murder his father so that it will fix
his life he thinks it'll fix his life of
he kills his father but it gets even
more interesting so on the TV show
we know that zoom knows all about
Barry's life how did he know that Linda
Park was his girlfriend how did he know
to send doppelganger dr. light well in
the comics Daniel West has this weird
psychic connection to other people with
the Speed Force he can sense them that
helps him track them down so that he can
take their Speed Force doesn't that
sound kind of like what zoom is doing
like somehow he just knows things about
Barry without ever having met him and I
know a lot of you are like well if Wally
West is zoom then how come he's shorter
isn't zoom supposed to be taller well
keep this in mind as Daniel West absorbs
more Speed Force he grows like he starts
to Hulk out he gets really huge so zoom
looks like he's been twisted by the
Speed Force turned into a monster like
Daniel West gets turned into a monster
when he takes in enough speed force so
here is my big question for you guys let
me know in the comments if you know the
new 52 storyline of the reverse-flash in
Daniel West do you think that the TV
show is doing a version of that with the
Wally West character if Daniel West is
trying to get back to that moment he was
happy the last moment he was happy and
that is also what wally west literally
just said that he is doing in this
episode i raised because i'm trying to
get back to this moment
now I'll say there's still a couple
other possibilities but I just I feel
like based on what happened in this
episode there's more compelling evidence
for wally west on earth-2 with a daniel
west arc from the new 52 comics but i
think i mentioned most of the Easter
eggs already the comic book characters
the storylines that they're doing the
character arcs they've taken but the one
really cool one is the bait line that
Joe West has I'm using you as bait you
like to fish with bait I do too all the
way back to Barry's dad who was fishing
in his time away from Central City so
there's this running theme of fish in
Bakke going across the entire flash
season as well as legends of tomorrow
captain Colt had this line in a legends
of tomorrow episode where he's like so
you're saying we have to fish or cut
bait that means for the rest of the
season you guys really need to look out
for references to bait or fishing just a
really fun in joke that the show has I'm
curious to see if it becomes more
meaningful like if they tie it to the
central arc of the series in this big
zoom plot oh and one more if you look at
the colors of Wally's right here it's
totally kid flash colors the the initial
Wally West yellow flash costume I know
Bart Allen wore a yellow costume too but
originally in the comics when Wally
first became kid flash he wore costumes
that looked exactly like Barry's it was
red and eventually they gave him a
yellow costume so this is just a really
awesome hat tip to that but the really
big news is this weekend is the Super
Bowl if you don't know what that is
don't worry it's just a time when a
bunch of really big trailers get dropped
it's mostly gonna be Marvel and x-men
universe stuff like Deadpool x-men
apocalypse Captain America Civil War
there might be some other stuff but
sunday will be a huge day for trailer so
I'll be posting a ton of videos then why
you guys wait for all that stuff to post
you can click here for all my flash
arrow legends of tomorrow videos that
you guys need to catch up on and you can
click here for my Star Wars The Force
awakens lego video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight